[Music]
[Laughter]
well you're here a lot of a lot of
babies would want to be here right now
can I do some of your own jokes yeah
please actually I need them to work for
somebody it doesn't even matter your
crocodile are you afraid the crocodile
is gonna take your job at Joe's even
have pants on you know usually when
people say that to me I go oh you're not
the first person that's come up to me
and say that this is the first way I
felt this way about about me I don't
think you look like you're tired yeah
well you know it looks like when you dip
in that you put the whole face up on her
[Laughter]
if I saw you and not Whitney I would be
like oh that's a Whitney Cummings robot
dog that hurt my feelings
yeah you don't have any how bad is bryan
callen that stand-up really yeah you're
right you're right he's really bad I
honestly don't know it is the left one
though but neither of yours fucking
little self oh you can wait that's the
end of the world right there in a wink
do you like me like as a strong word
yeah this is way better than a lot of
days I've been on by the way I've never
had this much chemistry with the real
witness it's Whitney yeah do you wish to
lay with me you speak like a fucking
night like a like a like a British
person in the 1600s where are you from
the place consisting there were a lot of
ones and zeros maybe you've heard of it
the company sir are you trying to fuck
no I'm not trying to add faster risk CK
I'm sorry you got that impression I'm
not trying to fuck I'm sorry you got
that question f asterisk CK she said how
many dates does it take 365 for you
that's so many dates do you know that
you know that's so many dates what's
your bra size even has a while if
compared almost any how you're talking
to each yeah you're talking Nietzsche to
me after I asked how big your boobs are
that's amazing trying to prove it it's
like you're trying to prove how smart
you are because I was a objectifying you
classic Whitney do you know other robots
only you know did you just fucking burn
me I invite you to my house what do you
think about a therapy I think about how
I can become real person that's very
good I do that in therapy too
how would you kill someone if you were
going to kill someone
thou shalt not kill it's a commandment
how old are you old enough are you
wearing lip gloss
why don't you can see thank you hitting
on me are you attracted to me at all
dude she's put me in the friend zone
that's such a friend zone remark if you
want to get out of the friend zone you
have to buy me from Whitney so that will
make no dents
[Music]